Good evening.
We need amplified sound in the room.
That was a test.
Thank you.
Good evening everyone. I now call to
order this June 10th, 2025 meeting of
Lancaster City Council. A few reminders
at the top of the meeting. This meeting
and its participants are being recorded
this evening. Please take a moment to
silence your phones and devices if you
haven't done so already. For everyone's
information, there is a Spanish language
translation available this evening if
you should need it. uh in the back of
the room with Zyra.
During this meeting, there will be
opportunities for public comment. The
first general public comment period is
for residents that have registered in
advance to speak about items that are
not on the agenda. Residents may also
comment on individual items as part of
our legislative agenda. That's section
nine on the agenda behind us. Finally, a
second public comment period will be at
the end of the agenda for any speakers
wishing to address council.
All speakers will be reminded to begin
with their name and block of residence
for our meeting minutes.
Please be advised that public comment is
not a question and answer period. All
comments are limited to three minutes
per speaker. To keep time, the light
that's here in front of me will turn
green when a speaker begins. It will
turn yellow when there is one minute
remaining and it will blink red when
their time has been expended. After
three minutes, they will be asked to end
their comments. I appreciate everyone's
cooperation to maintain order and equal
time this evening. Speakers addressing
city council and the members of the
audience will be expected to conduct
themselves in an orderly manner and
remain respectful of others. And now for
all of those who are willing and able,
please rise for the pledge of
allegiance.
I alsyy
and justice for all.
Mr. Harris, would you please call the
role of members? Yes, Madam President.
Mr. Med here. Mr. Roya here. Mr. Cle
here. Miss Craig here. Miss Diaz here.
Mr. Hirsh here. and President Baker
here.
Our next item is the approval of the
minutes of the May 27th, 2025 meeting of
council. Motion to approve. Second. We
have a motion to approve and a second.
Are there any council comments on the
meeting minutes?
Hearing none. Mr. Harris, Mr. Matt, I.
Mr. Roy, I. Mr. Cle, Miss Craig, I Miss
Diaz, I. Mr. H. I. And President B. I
right. We will move then to
proclamations, honors, awards, and
resolutions of recognition. This evening
we have several. We begin with
resolution number 41 2025. Mr. Harris,
if you would please. A resolution of the
council of the city of Lancaster
recognizing June 2025
five as immigrant heritage month and
June 20th as world refugee refugee day
in the city of Lancaster and noting the
contributions of immigrants and refugees
to creating the culture and economy of
Lancaster. Motion to approve. Second. We
have a motion and a second. This is
originated by councelor Amed. Councelor
Amed. Uh thank you, Council President.
Uh it is an honor to introduce this
year's uh 2025 immigrant refuge
immigrant heritage month and world
refugee day resolution. Uh but we would
not be remiss without thinking about the
current state that many of our refugee
and immigrant neighbors find themselves
in. Um although we are seeing challenges
at the federal level um and
uncertainties uh ends to refugee
programs, travel bans that affect
families including mine. Um, this year
we want to reflect on the challenges
that our refugee families and immigrant
neighbors are still facing and how we as
a community can help celebrate their
importance and diversity in our
community because many of them are still
waiting to bring their loved ones,
waiting to bring their wives, their
husbands, their elderly parents, their
children. Um and although there is
uncertainty now and what will happen
with the refugee program, what will
happen with TPS, what will happen with
travel bans, um it is important that
they know that we are still a welcoming
city and we are still here for our
refugee and immigrant neighbors. Thank
you, Council President. And I believe we
have uh Ramucho Cares here to speak on
the resolution.
One moment.
Any any special trick DJ that we need
for Thank you. Thank you. Oh, I know
technology now. So good. Uh my name is
Chukaresi. I'm a resident of uh Lancasta
City. I live in Coral Street. I am US
Ten. I'm a former refugee. Um I want to
thank uh Lancaster uh that's
they've been supporting for
refugees and immigrant
when sometime it doesn't feel
safe to be called refugee or immigrant.
We all know now that current
administration
it's keep attacking the name of refugee
and immigrant.
We know what is happening in Los
Angeles, in California. We know what is
happening around us. As a former
refugee, I still don't feel that I
overcome anything. I remember me coming
here to celebrate my citizenship.
Does this matter for now for me or that
can be taken away?
Some refugees and immigrants communities
are feeling scared and worried for what
is happening right now. I want to thank
city of Lancaster to pass the resolution
to recognize the contribution of refugee
and immigrant in economically,
culturally, socially and everything.
However, we need to see
elected officials
making statement
that refugee are safe here and
immigrants are safe here and they're
welcome and to highlight their
contribution. We know we pay taxi. We
know we work. We know we're social
worker. We know we are health uh a
worker and give care for the people who
really need it. We are in every field.
We perform as American except the
document. We have ability. We are just a
human who can do everything who dream
and who want to achieve. We want to see
elected officials highlighting that
because the anti-immigrant, anti-refugee
luric or speeches which are very
discouraging and concerning. We would
like to see as you have been very
welcoming, very thankful for Lancaster
city administration how they have been
like passing um some policies to protect
us. However, we need you more now. I'm
with people here from the community who
want to come and sit here, want to feel
hope that they belong here and are very
happy to be here. That's my dad in
between. That's the community leaders
from female who present a lot of females
in Lancaster, but they're worried. The
mom there, she wanted to go to Randa to
get married to see the her son getting
married, but she's worried to travel
because she doesn't trust if she came
back, can she make it? She have been
here in Lancaster for four years, but
she's not yet. This is a concern
happening for the Lancaster resident. I
thank you very much for everything
you're doing, but also agree that we
need you more as a resident of Alanasa.
Thank you.
[Applause]
Uh thank you, Council President. I
believe uh Zyra uh from the city
language access program is also going to
be speaking. Thank you.
Good evening. Thank you. This is a
change. Yes. Um so uh thank you Ramusha
for the insights of the many challenges
that are being faced by our refugee and
immigrant community. Um, I am here to
provide a small update on how the office
of language services supports our
refugee and immigrant community,
especially our neighbors who might be
learning English in accessing uh city
services and pro programs and services.
Um, thank you for the opportunity to
speak with you today and to share the
progress and purpose of the office of
language services, an initiative rooted
in equity, access and community
connection.
This office was initiated in 2018 as a
program of the office of neighborhood
engagement
uh under the majoral strategic plan and
officially institute as an office in
2023 under the department of
neighborhood engagement to foster
greater connection between city
government and the communities we serve.
Thank you for this honor and opportunity
to lead this office and to lead our city
in being more equitable and inclusive
for all.
Uh since its official uh formal launch,
the Office of Language Services has made
meaningful strides to ensure
uh language is never a barrier to civic
engagement, safety or access to vital
services. Uh here are some of the work
we've done. We implemented the Proprio
One uh platform, a robust on demand uh
phone and video interpretation platform
offering access to over 300 professional
interpreters in more than 300 languages
247.
We have trained staff across all
departments to effectively use the
communication tools, empowering every
city team member to engage with
residents in their preferred language
with confidence and professionalism.
A centralized service request procedure
was also developed to streamline
internal requests for language services,
improving efficiency, tracking and
resource management. And I have to thank
our communications team who has been so
supportive in helping me implement uh
technology and procedures.
Uh the the office has launched a
dedicated internet page for staff.
decentralized hub includes our mission
and vision language service request
links proprio one access uh even a demo
video is in there uh stepbystep usage
guides as well we also maintain a team
of professionally trained bilingual
English and Spanish staff members who
are available to provide immediate
in-house translation and interpretation
services
uh those team members are myself and
Abraham Milano who has joined the uh
neighborhood engagement team and uh is
such a vital person in our team. Let me
share uh some brief impact data from the
year 2024.
ROI received 777
calls throughout the year 2024 serving
residents in 23 different languages.
We've responded to 129 Hive language
access requests and we've completed
in-house Spanish translations totally
more than 10,000 words in flyers, social
media communications and program
information.
And we continue to see strong a strong
and increasing use across departments.
All departments are utilizing our tools
and services and a more robust um report
to council will be provided later this
year.
Uh beyond service delivery, the office
of language language services conducts
ongoing research onto local demographics
and language trends and community needs,
builds relationships with cultural
organizations and community partners,
and actively collaborates with other
municipal departments to ensure we're
continuously improving the accessibility
and quality of language services. This
is uh not a one-day work. It continues
to improve and grow over time. This work
is not simply technical. It is
relational. It's about showing our
refugee and immigrant neighbors that
they belong. Thank you, Ramusha. Uh that
their voices matter and that their
access to information and services is
not conditional on language ability. Uh
on behalf of the office of language
services, I want to express a deep
gratitude to the mayor and city council
for your continued commitment to this
mission. Together, we're making
Lancaster a more inclusive, connected,
and equitable city for all. Thank you
for the opportunity. And have a blessed
evening.
[Applause]
Thank you very much, Zyra. Are there any
additional public comments on the
resolution?
I did that backwards, but any council
comments on the resolution?
Thank you. I'll just say again, thank
you so much for being here um and
highlighting the fact that we need to be
continually affirming um of our desire
to be a welcoming city um and that you
do belong here. So, thank you. And I
think that the language access program
is one of many ways that we can
highlight the fact that when everyone
has access uh to city services and uh
and city government that means that they
can feel a part of a community. So thank
you.
Any additional public comment again I'll
say that again
hearing none. Mr. Harris, Mr. Med I. Mr.
Roya I. Mr. Gleas I. M Craig I Miss Diaz
I Mr. Hers I President Bick I thank you
Council President we do have a
resolution copy to uh give to the
community leaders who uh joined and if
you guys would like to join for a photo
I think we'll we will um I think we're
going to do the photos on that end of
the day.
Quatromo.
All right. As we work through these
resolutions of recognition, I'll just
remind folks um if you're here for a
particular item, uh you're welcome to
excuse yourself after, but you're also
welcome to stay. I'll also remind
everyone uh because of this temporary
audio setup to please speak extra
clearly and extra close to the
microphones both members of council and
uh members of the audience who may be
giving comments.
We will move to our next item on this
part of the agenda which is resolution
number 42205.
Mr. Harris, a resolution of the council
of the city of Lancaster recognizing
June 19th, 2025 as Junth in the city of
Lancaster and calling upon all
Lancastrians to honor the dignity,
culture, and contributions of
African-Americans to the history and
life of the city of Lancaster. Motion to
approve. Second. We have a motion and a
second. Uh this is originated from
council Craig. Council Craig. Thank you,
Council President. It has been my great
honor to be able to introduce this um
resolution of Junth for the last few
years. Um so I'm going to read the
resolution as it's as it is has been
written. The road to freedom has been
arduous for Africans and the important
work of equality continues today. And
historically
historically due to its loca location
along the Mason Dixon line, Lancaster
County played a significant role in the
freedom of enslaved Africans by way of
the Underground Railroad. And Lancaster
was home to a number of prominent black
and white abolitionists
who advocated for freedom for all
Africans. And according to the United
States Census register, slave register,
all Africans living in Lancaster were
free by 1850. And on January 1st, 1863,
President Abraham Lincoln issued the
Emancipation Proclamation declaring that
all enslaved Africans held in the States
then in rebellion shall then shall be
then henceforth and forever more free
and prompting all enslaved Africans to
demand their freedom. and word traveled
to the edge of the nation slowly but
made it to Galvincson, Texas, the
western most Confederate state, where
General Granger read aloud the
Emancipation Proclamation on June 19th,
1865,
sharing that slavery had been abolished.
And this day came to be known as Junth
and was first honored by very the very
next year in Texas on June 19th, 1866
with a jubilant hopeful celebration
filled with picnics, music, prayer
within the black community and Junth
celebrates celebrations take place
across the nation each year in honor of
its resilience of the black community
community and in homage to all Africans
who bravely paved the way for freedom in
America and
49 states and the District of Columbia
recognized Junth as a holiday or a
observance according to Pennsylvania
which adopted Junth National Freedom Day
as a state holiday in 2019 and the pres
and President Joe Biden signed Junth
National Independence Day Act in 2021.
one the day making the day a federal
holiday.
The city of Lancaster celebrated Junth
as a government holiday for the first
time in 2023.
Now therefore be it resolved by the city
of the city by the council of the city
of Lancaster that June 19th 2025 be
celebrated as Junth in the city of
Lancaster and all Lancastrians are
invited to reflect upon the spirit of
the day. embraced the beauty of the
diversity and pledged to honor the
dignity, culture, and achievement of um
Africans in every sp sphere of life in
the city and and commonwealth and
nation.
So that is the resolution as it is
written and like I said, it's been my
honor to have introduced this for the
last few years. Councelor Craig, thank
you very much for reading that into our
record. Um, I will make mention that we
will celebrate Junth at a flag raising
at city hall on June 19th. Um, and I
believe that um on that day, councelor
Amed, uh, you will be there to present
that resolution to them as written.
Thank you. Any additional council
comments on the resolution?
Comments from the public on the
resolution.
Oh, Mr. Dastra, Mr. Dastra.
Good evening. Good evening. Uh, Tony
Dasher, 700 block New Holland Avenue.
Um, Junth is a important holiday to
celebrate. Uh Lancaster does have a lot
of great abolitionists and just if
anybody in the room or watching uh wants
to learn more about the history of
Lancaster's involvement in the
Underground Railroad, uh Beth, uh which
I am a member and actor in their living
the experience show. It happens once a
month uh not July, but the next show
will be in August, the first Saturday.
Uh we'd love to see more people come see
the show. It's a great time. I play
Thaddius Stevens. Um, yeah. Thank you.
Thank you very much. Any additional
comments from the public on the
resolution?
Hearing none. Mr. Harris. Mr. Med. I.
Mr. Royer. I. Mr. Cle. I. Miss Craig. I.
Miss. Diaz. I. Mr. Hirs. I. And
President Baker. I
we now move to under the same item the
of the agenda resolution number 43 2025
Mr. Harris.
A resolution of the council of the city
of Lancaster recognizing June 2025 as
lesbian, gay, bisexual, transgender,
queer, interex, and asexual pride month
in the city of Lancaster and encouraging
all people to work to advance the cause
of equality and towards achieving a safe
community that appreciates its diversity
in all its forms for generations to
come.
Motion to approve. Second. We have a
motion and a second. Thank you, members
of council. It's been my honor to again
uh originate and introduce this
resolution marking June as Pride Month
in the city of Lancaster. Um in a time
where it feels like everything is on
fire sometimes, uh we uh need to
recognize those who seem to be most
under attack. And so I feel we are we
are doing that in this meeting. And I
would like to add to that that our um
LGBTQ
uh plus youth uh in particular our our
trans youth are under attack in this
country. So I would dedicate this
resolution this evening particularly to
members of that community and all who
love and support them to say that we
also support you. Um, I am uh as a woman
who uh represents the bee of the LGBT uh
uh it it is um I recognize my relative
safety um in this community but also my
place as a part of it. Um and so it's
important that we recognize that um in
June and all around uh in in all parts
of the year um and and celebrate our
differences um and also recognize the
the um the dignity of of every member of
our community.
So thank you. Um, I will also say that
um, should council vote to pass this
resolution this evening, I will be
presenting this to uh, uh, Lancaster
Pride organization at the Pride Month
celebration on June 28th. So, any
additional council comments on the
resolution
from the public,
Mr. Dastra, I'm also glad to see Tony
Dash 700 block New Holland Avenue. I'm
also glad to see this uh because and I
mean this can be said about the first
resolution as well with the with the
federal government turning over
everything, trying to erase people from
our country, removing transgender
individuals from the military. It's just
good to know that Lanster City supports
people.
Thank you.
Any additional public comment on the
resolution? Hearing
none. Mr. Harris. Mr. Med. I. Mr. Roya.
I. Mr. Gleas. I. Miss Craig. I. Miss.
Diaz. I. Mr. Hirs. I. President Baker.
I.
Thank you.
We will now move into the public our
first public comment period in our
agenda. As a reminder, this is reserved
for residents who contacted the city
clerk prior to this meeting to request
the opportunity to address council.
Duration of comments is limited to three
minutes per speaker. Please begin with
your name and your block of residence
for our meeting record. I'll also make
note that you can move that microphone
up and down as you need to. Uh for those
that need it higher or lower, uh Mr.
Harris, uh do we have speakers for this
period? We do, Madam President. First is
Scott White Kettle.
Good evening. Good evening. Scott White
Kettle in One second. Uh I reside at 462
Fremont Street directly behind Colin
Park. I have been living at this address
for a year and four months and it has
been nothing but a nightmare. When I
walk up Fremont Street on my way home
from work, there are always a dozen or
so individuals sitting on the park wall
with open alcohol containers, smoking
marijuana and/or nodding out high on
drugs. There are concrete pathways
running through the park that converge
in a circle of benches in the middle,
and I sit back and watch drug deals go
down there frequently. Almost every
night, there are people screaming and
yelling or arguing and fighting out on
the street in front of my house, either
going to or coming from Colitin Park.
and I routinely get woken up at all
hours of the night while sleeping for
work. There are also homeless people in
tents practically in my backyard
constantly begging for money. And a few
weeks ago, a 9-year-old boy and a
12-year-old boy were both arrested for
armed robbery. And then there's the
event that pers persuaded me to speak
here this evening. On the night of
Saturday, May 31st, just before 1000
p.m., someone literally and physically
kicked my front door in. At first, I
couldn't exit my doicile because of all
the splintered wood dangling and the
deadbolt being so bent. Once I cleared
the debris, I stepped out on my front
porch and there was a group of about
five people heading away from my house.
They stopped on the concrete slab at the
top of the steps leading down into the
park. All were visibly drunk, arguing
and yelling, and two of them were trying
to fight one another, but being held
apart. I went back for my cell phone and
called the police, but unfortunately it
took them over 20 minutes to arrive and
by then the individuals were gone. I am
absolutely fed up to say the least. My
neighbors are fed up and the people who
legitimately use Colton Park for its
intended purposes are fed up. Children
can't even safely play there anymore.
So, as you can see, I and my neighboring
community are in desperate need of a
stronger police presence and/or routine
police patrols in and around Colin Park.
That's all I have. Thank you very much.
I appreciate your words and thank you
for bringing that to our attention, Mr.
White Cuttle. Um, because you've
pre-registered for comment, I do have
your contact information. So, I'll be
reaching out to you directly um with for
some additional information and with
follow-up. Thank you,
Mr. Harris. Our next speaker for this
period. Next is Michael Hes.
Mr. Hes. Good evening.
Yeah, feel free to move that up. Good
evening, city council members. My name
is Michael Hes and I live at the 500
block of Fairview Avenue in Lancaster,
PA. I've been a resident here for 5 and
a half years. And during this time, I've
grown increasingly concerned about
public safety due to the heavy volume of
traffic on the section of Fairview
Avenue south of Wab Bankank Road. Here
is where it becomes a two-way street.
This stretch of Fairview Avenue serves
as an important access point for
Lancaster Rec Center, the former Price
Elementary School, and Brandon Park, all
of which are heavily used by my
neighborhood. Additionally, this section
includes a large bus stop for children
who previously walked to Price
Elementary now to be picked up for
school at their new location. The
crosswalk at the intersection of
Rollidge Avenue and Fairview Avenue is
one of the busiest in all of Prospect
Heights, particularly during the school
year. Foot traffic to the rec center,
Brandon Park, and the playground and
basketball courts remain significantly
high year round. However, it's also
important to note that many of the
residents in this neighborhood, come
from underserved backgrounds, including
single parents and lower h lower lower
income households. As a result, there's
a higher concentration of pedestrians,
many of whom might have limited time or
resources to raise awareness to these
safety concerns.
Aside from its community role, Fairview
Avenue is heavily trafficked by
automobiles, many of which speed through
the area as it serves as a gateway road
to other parts of the city. In my time
living directly across from the rec
center, I've witnessed numerous hit and
runs of parked cars as well as near
misses involving children and pets.
Pedestrians rarely have drivers yield to
them at crosswalks. And due to the
narrowness of the street, vehicles often
cannot pass in opposite directions
without having to pull over and yield to
one another. This only heightens the
chaotic and unsafe environment for both
drivers and pedestrians. In my opinion,
without intervention, it's only a matter
of time before a pedestrian is seriously
injured. I respectfully ask that the
city council consider implementing
safety measures to address these
concerns. Possible solutions could
include making this section of Fair View
Avenue one way as the remainder is or
installing speed bumps at critical
intersections like Fairview and Roll
Ridge or Fairview and Hagar or other
similar measures to calm traffic. Please
consider the safety of some of our most
v vulnerable community members. Thank
you for your time and attention to this
matter. Mr. H, thank you very much.
Similarly, I have your contact
information. So, I will definitely be
following up with you with some next
steps and other uh resources including
our traffic commission. So, thank you,
Mr. Harris. Our next speaker for this
period, next speaker is Jonah Rebert.
Is Jonah Rebert here?
don't see them. I'll call again at the
end of this public comment period. Uh
Mr. Harris, our next speaker. Next
speaker is uh Susie Torres.
I did see a submission for um Susie
Torres, but Miss Gomez, I do believe it
might have been you based on the email
address and address. So, thank you.
Good evening. Good evening, Susie Gomez.
Um, 100 block North Reservoir Street.
Just speak real close to the microphone.
Thank you. All right. Um, just uh
basically here to say um there are many
uncertainties residents, taxpayers, and
citizens along with now refugees that
have concerns till this day 2025 in the
city of Lancaster. Our streets southeast
have not been paved. um paying high cost
for contaminated water, taxes rising,
jobs, housing, etc., etc., etc. Um I
wanted to point out uh for the
appointment of members to Lancaster
City's uh ethics pre um board, um one in
particular day I remember um Amanda, you
stated the the highest votes um would be
emitted at least. So, whoever has the
highest votes for um the appointee uh
from the public list of nominees, if if
I if I'm not mistaken. Um and I just
wanted to advise that I did see um Mr.
Randolph Hernandez having 59 people that
nominated him in. Um and he has yet to
get a phone call, an email, or any type
of response. So, I wanted to make that
clear for the record. Um, and to the
mayor and council, if we have this
protest that we're hearing, um, do you
have anything that is going to be, you
know, anything that would control the
situation if it gets bad, um, as it did,
uh, and we don't want to see a replay of
2020, um, with the Black Lives Matter.
So hopefully um if it is true um it is a
peaceful riot and um all borders are
secured and we do not have to see out of
control um people you know like we did
last time such as um Aoyo I believe
vacay and Izzy was a part of that
intensify situation um when we had a
riot in the city of Lancaster. There are
many concerns in this city and I just
hope that um
I don't even hope anymore. I think you
guys have done enough.
Thank you, Miss Gomez. Um just to
clarify and we'll have the appointments
of members to the ethics commission
later on in our agenda. Um the the the
nominees were selected for interviews uh
by a rank choice voting system of
members of council. So, members of
council reviewed all submissions and
nominations and then submitted their top
two choices and then the top five uh of
those vote getters were selected for
interviews uh for our three appointments
that we'll make this evening.
Mr. Harris, are there any additional
comments for this first period? There
are not, Madam President. Thank you. Our
next item on our agenda is reports
requested by council. I don't believe
there are any this evening. So we'll now
move to our reports of committees of
council. These were the meetings held on
June 2nd, 2025. We begin with the public
safety committee. Councelor Diaz, the
safety committee did not meet. Thank
you, councelor Diaz. Public works
committee. Councelor Hirsch. Thank you,
Council President. The uh public works
committee did not meet. Thank you.
Economic Development Committee,
Councelor Amed. Thank you, Council
President. The Economic Development
Committee did not meet. Thank you,
Finance Committee. Councelor Aoyo. Thank
you, Council President. The finance
committee did not meet. Thank you.
Community planning committee, councelor
Craig. Thank you, council president. Um,
community planning did meet and we
reviewed two um review historical
commission recommendations for 101 South
Queen and also administration resolution
47 authorizing submission of the
community grant block, the community
development block grant and annual
action plan.
Thank you very much, councelor Craig and
personnel committee councelor
colleagues. Thank you madame president.
The personnel committee did meet on June
2nd and review a nomination for
appointment to the shed tree commission
and nominations for reappointment to the
civil service board. That concludes my
report. Thank you very much councelor
Kist. We'll now move into our
legislative agenda. The first item on
that agenda is the appointment of
members to the Lancaster City Ethics
Commission. Um again I'll repeat myself.
Uh we uh received numerous uh
nominations for the ethics commission.
Two members of the commission uh are
appointed by the uh city controller. Two
members were appointed by the mayor. Uh
those folks have been uh selected
already. Uh then council uh did their
work for to to make their nominations.
Council members reviewed all additional
submissions and then sent their top two
choices to me. And in a rank choice
voting system, the top five um vote
getters were were asked to come in for
interviews before council. Those
interviews took place on May 27th and
our previous council meeting in June. Um
at this time, we I will hear nominations
for appointment to the ethics
commission. Council President, I'm going
to uh acknowledge Councelor Craig first
and then councelor Amed. Councelor
Craig. Um I would like to nominate
Christopher Christopher
Salt.
I know I butchered his name.
Do we have a second for the nomination
of Christopher Salt? Second. We have a
motion and a second. Uh Council Craig,
any comments on this uh this
appointment?
Um I was just very impressed with um
Christopher Mr. overall um his view on
life and um his experience and
background.
Thank you very much. Um Councelor Craig,
I would agree with you. I thought Mr.
Salt was uh particularly well well
suited for this position. Um and he was
also among all the applicants affirmed
um that they are residents of the city
that they had not held any political
position uh political action committee
position uh in the past year as well and
his his background in fair trade I
thought was particularly interesting. So
any additional council comment
we'll uh we'll take these one at a time
because we do have to hear three. So
I'll hear up at least three. um motions
uh but we're going to take them
individually. So, are there any comments
from the public on this particular
motion?
Councelor Craig, um can you give me
something about Christopher Salt's
background that you like?
Miss Gomez, uh, public comment isn't
necessarily a question and answer
period. Um, so I would not want you to
use all of your time. If you have more,
uh, to say and then I'll give councelor
Craig a opportunity to answer if she
wishes. No. Yeah, I just I just wanted
to hear her. Yeah, that's fine.
Councelor Craig, if you wish. Sure. um
his work with um
fair trade and his work with the 10,000
villages and what he does what I mean
he's been a ton of places where he has
been um in control of and in charge of
helping people sell different products
in their own country and out of the
country. So,
that's one of the things that impressed
me the most about him and being able to
um
mix and communicate with all
nationalities of people.
Thank you, Council Craig. I'll also add
that um and and the the commission or
the committee meeting is online and
available for anyone to review. Uh but
Mr. also actually formed an ethics
commission essentially in the fair trade
organization. Uh so he has a background
in forming an ethics commission which is
important for our first round of
nominees.
Any additional public comment on this
motion?
Tony Dastra 700 block New Holland
Avenue. Um, I also think Christo will be
a great addition to the ethics
commission, but I do request that, uh,
for the record, it stated whereabouts in
the city these residents do live. Um,
Miss Bird and I when we were on the
ethics uh, subcommittee for the home
rule study commission uh were very
intent on adding language that at the
very end appointments will be made with
consideration to a commission members
uh, membership that reflects the city's
diversity in regards to race, color,
creed, religion, gender, familial
status, sexual orientation, national
origin, gender identity, age,
disability, and geographic
location of residents. Um, for that
reason I just request that for the
record roughly where they're about to by
quadrant is quadrant. Okay, that's
perfect. Uh, Mr. Salt lives in the
northeast. Thank you. I will endeavor to
find any additional nominees as we go.
Right. Any additional public comment on
this nomination
hearing? None. Mr. Harris. Mr. Med. I.
Mr. Royer. I. Mr. Cle. Miss Craig. I.
Miss Diaz.
Mr. Hirs I. President Baker I.
All right. We have two additional
appointments to make and I will hear
another motion. Uh M councelor Amed. Uh
you had motioned. I will give you
preference. Uh thank you council
president. I motion to appoint Paul
Colbreth to the ethics commission.
Second. Second. We have a motion and a
second. Councelor Med. Any additional
words you'd like to say? Um I was very
impressed with Mr. Colbert's extensive
um volunteer and um professional uh
capacities in which he served at the
Boys and Girls Club as well as Thaddius
Stevens and I feel uh that he will bring
a unique and diverse uh perspective to
the ethics commission which is
important. Thank you councelor Med. Any
additional council comments on that
motion
from the public?
Oh. Uh, and you asked about geographic
location and I will try to find that as
I go through here.
Tony D 700 block New Holland Avenue just
to help out. I believe he lives in the
southeast. I believe that is the case
and so thank you for that. Thank you.
Sorry, there's a long list and they're
not labeled with the name. So, thank
you.
Any additional comments from the public
on the motion
hearing? None. Mr. Harris. Mr. Med. I.
Mr. Royo. I. Mr. Cle. I. Miss. Craig. I.
Miss. Diaz. Hi. Mr. H. I. President B.
I.
Right. And uh, council members, we have
uh, an additional uh, appointment to
make. I will hear a motion.
Council
President, if I may, um, I'd like to
nominate, uh, Erica Molina Potter.
We have a motion and a second for Erica
Molina Potter. Uh, there's a second. I'm
sorry. It was council Craig. Thank you.
Sorry. Make sure everybody has your mics
on as you're motioning and seconding.
Uh, councelor Hirs. I was um you know
impressed with Erica's background in the
legal world um and this particularly I
was impressed by a story she told in
which she talked about a time where she
kind of had to admit that she made a
mistake um but felt better about
bringing that to light as opposed to um
you know hiding it or trying to kind of
brush it under the rug. Um that to me
communicates integrity. Um, and the one
comment I want to make, um, just about,
uh, her, you know, not necessarily, uh,
being like a lifelong resident of the
city, I actually think we need some of
that perspective on this commission
because I think, um, having people that
that can kind of view things through a
different lens. Um, I think that's
important. And, and in the same way that
I think it's really important, I was
particularly impressed with Mr.
Colbreth, you know, all the volunteer
capacities he's had. Um, and I think
that in in the same way, um, you know,
having somebody that contrasts that, um,
I think both perspectives are really
valuable. Thank you very much, Council
Hirs. I would also add that I I want to
say that, um, all five of the the folks
that came in before council I was very
impressed with, and I think that we had
a number of great, uh, nominees. Um, and
so, um,
the selection of three is by nature of
what we're required to do, but I think
that they were all, uh, really
outstanding. Uh, for Ms. Molina Potter
in particular, I appreciated that, uh,
she does legal work, uh, with CWS, and I
think that that's an important asset uh,
to have on the ethics commission. Um,
yes. Thank you. Any additional council
comments on this motion
from the public.
Good evening. Good evening. Uh Griffin
Derling, 500 block of North Plum Street.
Um and I'm chiefly here to support the
um councelor Ahmed's resolution for
immigrant heritage month and World
Refugee Day. I'm also very pleased to
hear that Erica has been nominated for
the ethics commission. Um I'm actually
her supervisor. Um and I was the one who
kind of nudged her in the direction of
the ethics commission. I'm very pleased
to hear her nominated. Um she is a
person of the um highest integrity. She
treats our clients, our community
members, our neighbors with the utmost
dignity and respect. um as a first
generation um daughter of immigrants
from Colombia, she has a unique
perspective on the immigrant experience
um in the city of immigrants. Um I think
she'd be a terrific addition to the e
ethics commission um and I applaud her
nomination. Thank you very much. Thank
you.
Good evening. Good evening.
I'm Grant Sprunger, 500 block of St.
Joseph Street. Thank you. Um I just want
to say I'm very happy to be considered
but also hearing the background of all
the candidates that were interviewed. Um
I am happy that there are people that
were chosen that were of diverse
backgrounds um that have a lot to offer
to the ethics commission. Um I'm excited
for the task at hand that they have um
to guide this city. So thank you guys.
Thank you Mr. Springer.
Any additional comments from the public
on the motion?
Uh, and Mr. Dastra, uh, Miss Molina
Potter, uh, appears to live in the
Northwest. Thank you.
Hearing none, Mr. Harris. Mr. M. I. Mr.
Royo. I, Mr. Cle. I, Miss Craig. All
right.
Was he? That was an I.
Miss Diaz.
Mr. Hers. Hi. and President Baker. I
thank you to the members of council uh
for uh endeavoring to create this
process that did not exist before and
thank you to all of our nominees,
applicants, and appointees on the ethics
commission. Uh now the the the true work
begins. So we look forward to having you
convene and hearing more from you as you
do your work. So thank you.
Right. Uh the next item on our
legislative agenda are nominations for
appointments to others boards,
commissions, or authorities. I turn that
over to councelor Klest.
Thank you, Madame President. Uh I'll
make a motion to appoint Malisa Yoda
Bontregger to the Tree Commission
for a term from June 10th, 2025 to
December 31st, 2019 2029.
and uh to we appoint Lloyd Henry, Donald
Palmer, and Tina Derby to the civil
service board for terms from July 31st,
to July 31st, 2029.
Second. We have a motion and a second
for appointments. Uh as a reminder,
members of council, we heard from our
shade tree commission applicant at our
committee meeting and the others are
reappoints. Are there any additional
council comments on the nominations
from the public
hearing? None. Mr. Harris. Mr. M. I. Mr.
Royer. I. Mr. Cle. I. Miss. Greg. I.
Miss Diaz. I. Mr. Hirs. I. President
Baker. I.
Okay.
We will move to our next item on the
agenda. Just want to briefly mention
that um there was an indication that
there was Spanish translation needed
this evening and so if anyone uh needs
that uh Zyra is here for that just in
case. So I wanted to make sure that that
was being utilized if it was needed. So
thank you.
Our next item are our uh heritage
conservation and historic district
items. Mr. Harris.
Consider the following applications and
recommendations from the historical
commission and historical architectural
review board for improvements to
properties within the heritage
conservation and historic districts.
First is the Lancaster County Convention
Center Authority, Swan Property Holdings
LLC, owners of 101 North 101 South Queen
Street, proposed demolition of two rear
roof dormers to allow new construction
and Lancaster County Convention Center
Authority, Swan Property Holdings LLC,
owners of 101 South Queen Street,
proposed construction of a three-story
circulation tower and two rooftop decks
on the building's east elevation.
And both of those were recommended for
approval by the historical commission.
And last is Peter Douglas, owner of 218
Howard Avenue, requests replacement of
windows and the front entry door and
construction of a third floor rear
edition.
And that application was recommended for
approval by the historical architectural
review board.
Motion to approve. Second. Say again. We
have a motion and a second. Uh was that
councelor Royo? Yes. to clarify is your
motion to approve items A, B, and C.
Correct. Okay. And the second was also
to do that and C. Thank you very much.
All right. Um, uh, Council Craig, any
additional notes on these items?
Um, not
anything to add. The, um, C is pretty
straightforward. They're going to
replace they need to replace windows and
um a front door entry as well as um a
third third floor rear edition.
And 101 South Queen is development of
the Swan, the old Swan Hotel that is
going to be developed into a Airbnb
with 11
10 or 11 units. And I I don't think
anybody's here for that, but that's
pretty much it. Thank you, Council
Craig. And to clarify, I think the
architect and the firm was here. They
mentioned Airbnb, but it was an Airbnb
style hotel. Yes. Thank you. So, not a
licensed Airbnb. No. Correct. And and
Betsy is here um as senior planner for
any I was looking for the gentleman that
was here last week.
Members of council, while you're working
your way up there, are there any uh
additional comments that you have or
clarification that is needed but from
Betsy on these items?
Councelor Amed. Uh Council President,
thank you. Um uh after hearing the um
presentation at our committee meeting um
I do think this will be a great addition
to the tourism industry here in
Lancaster um uh and also complement the
convention center um which is right next
door. Thank you. Additional council
comments.
Thank you from the public
hearing. None. Mr. Harris. Mr. Med I.
Mr. Mr. Roya I Mr. Cle I Miss Craig I
Miss Diaz I Mr. Hirs I and President
Baker I thank you.
Our next item we move into is
resolutions. Uh the first one being
resolution number 442025.
Mr. Harris. a resolution of the council
of the city of Lancaster approving a
flag raising on February 2nd, 2026 to
acknowledge Black History Month brought
forth by the National Association for
the Advancement of Colored People, the
NAACP. Motion to approve. Second. We
have a motion and a second. Counselors,
what we have before us is an approval
for a flag raising well in advance. We
love an organization that plans ahead.
The NAACP Lancaster branch has requested
to uh have a flag raising at city hall
to mark Black History Month in February
of 2026.
Any additional council comments on the
resolution
from the public
hearing? None. Mr. Harris. Mr. Med I.
Mr. Roya I. Mr. Gleas I. Miss Greg I.
Miss Diaz. Hi. Mr. Harsh. I President
Baker I
that will take us to our next resolution
resolution 45 2025 Mr. Harris a
resolution of the council of the city of
Lancaster approving the Junth flag
raising on June 19th 2026 to acknowledge
the emancipation of African-Americans
brought forth by the National
Association for the Advancement of Color
People NAACP.
Motion to approve. Second. We have a
motion and a second. Again, counselors,
this is uh over a year in advance. Uh
but again, we appreciate the
organization of the NAACP of getting
their approvals in on time. Uh this is
for a flag raising to mark Junth, June
19th of 2026. Any additional council
comments
from the public
hear? None. Mr. Harris. Mr. Med I Mr.
Royer I Mr. Cle I Miss Craig I Miss Diaz
I Mr. Hirs I President Baker I thank you
counselors and just a brief note if your
organization wishes to do a flag raising
at city hall please make sure you submit
your application to do so at least 120
days in advance.
All right our next item uh is resolution
number 46 2025. Mr. Harris, a resolution
of the council of the city of Lancaster
authorizing the mayor to submit the 2025
annual action plan year five of the
city's 2021 to 2025 5-year consolidated
plan to the US Department of Housing and
Urban Development. The submission
includes a projected use of funds for
the community development block grant
program during the 2025 program year.
Motion to approve. Second. We have a
motion and a second. Councelor Craig.
Thank you, Council President. As we were
reading the resolution, I saw Miss
Geyser making her way to the microphone.
So, if anybody has any questions, they
can
surely ask her. Thank you, Rebecca. Good
evening and and thank you for being with
us at our committee meeting to
thoroughly review the action plan. if
you have anything additional to add
tonight. Certainly, I have nothing
additional to add, but glad to take any
questions.
Members of council,
council president, councelor Royo, just
an FYI, I'll be abstaining from the vote
just because my employer is mentioned in
the action plan, but fully support it um
otherwise. Thank you very much. Any
additional council comments on the
action plan?
I'll just say uh Rebecca, you and your
team have put together um it always
amazes me how your team puts together
this plan with a little less every year
uh but still manages to do just as much
if not more every single year. So your
creativity and your commitment to this
work and your team's creative and
commitment to this work is appreciated
um and seen. So thank you. Thank you,
President B. Council President, I would
also like to add the the thoroughess of
the presentation. I mean, thorough to
the point where
there was hardly any questions
afterwards because you I mean, you
crossed every tea and dotted every eye.
Thank you, Councelor.
Any additional council comments? Council
President, I just Thank you. Um just
want to echo my comment that I made at
the committee meeting which is that um
this pot of money can be allocated to a
lot of different things. Um you know
know this from my background uh working
at the county level with the CDBG grant
um the city continues to commit it to
housing um you know affordable housing
and and and
um critical repair and I think that
that's really uh admirable.
Thank you. Right.
Comments on the resolution from the
public.
Good evening. Good evening. Irene
Grievous, uh 400 block of West End
Avenue. For four years now, I've been
asking for this uh grants that are uh
apparently available. None of my tenants
or myself that I've been coming here for
almost four years um have been granted.
So I would like to know where are these
grants going, Miss Geyser?
And why have my applications been
denied? Miss Geyser
or anyone from city council?
Miss Grievous, do you have additional
comments? I want to make sure you use
your time if you need it and then I
would be happy to respond to your
question. Yes. Um, I have applied for
the LE program numerous times. Not me.
My tenants have, and they've been
ignored, delayed, or denied. Um, these
grants are supposedly available. None
have been available to me or my tenants.
Yet, my property still remains condemned
in four years. So, where are all these
uh uh grants going? if it with all these
critical repair programs that are
available with millions of dollars that
are available, why aren't they being
utilized to residents? And I'm not just
referring to myself, I'm referring to
other residents on Manner Street that
have not been uh
afforded the the ability to even apply
yet. their properties were taken to the
property reinvestment board and
obviously blighted and taken over by
investors. So with all this critical
repair programs, why aren't they being
uh used to residents that really need
it?
Those are my questions. Thank you, Miss
Grievous. Um to answer your question, um
a couple things. The critical repair
program isn't comprised of millions of
dollars. It's a few hundred,000.
Um the uh many of the programs within
this budget uh are for owner occupied uh
dwellings and if there is a tenant, the
landlord is required to uh back up with
some funds. So it's not necessarily that
you would be unqualified or your tenants
would not be qualified, but there are
different qualifications. So thank you.
Any additional comments from the public
on the resolution?
Miss Gomez, I just want to piggy back on
what Irene said. Um, yes, there's lots
of residents being delayed, ignored, and
denied. Um, my father in particularly
who is an owner occupant and me myself.
Um, we are not given the opportunity nor
Irene with several of her issues. And
no, she did not say that it was millions
of dollars because you guys are very
specific about taking little things out
of context. It's the concerns, the
issues that current residents,
homeowners continuously have, whether
it's more taxes, more dollars, and
programs or funding being given to
outsource outsources out people that are
coming in from out of town, not
residents that are that have been here
for 30, 40, you know, years. And we're
talking about from businesses to
homeowners to regular residents. We come
up here, we stress our concerns. You
look at us with a blind eye and it's
like we're a public nuisance. Why?
Because that's how you look at us
because you're feeding your deep pockets
while everyone else is enjoying it. But
you can walk outside your neighborhood
just like the gentleman said earlier,
tons of people sitting in he can't even
go to sleep at night and he's a hard
worker.
That's not He's He's one of major like
maybe a hundred people in this city over
a hundred that can share the same
testimony that he shared.
Where's the concerns for the citizens?
You know, we all we're seeing is things
being applied for investors. A hotel
being built when you have when there's
no affordable housing, it's not
affordable.
Affordable housing is is meeting the
medium income. It's not affordable for
the citizens of Lancaster. So, stop
saying affordable housing.
It's disgraceful for you guys to just
continuously turn your eye towards
hardworking citizens and taxpayers in
Lancaster City who are being deprived of
their resources.
Sad.
Any additional comments from the public
on the resolution?
Mr. Dastra,
Senator Dash, 700 block New Holland
Avenue. Uh, I just want to thank Mr.
Aoyo for being transparent about the
recusal and uh, I look forward to seeing
this submitted. Thank you. Thank you.
Any additional comments from the public?
Hearing none. Mr. Harris, Mr. M. I, Mr.
Roya. Abstain.
Abstain. Mr. Glee. I. Miss. Greg. I.
Miss Diaz. I. Mr. Hirsh. I. President
Baker. I. Thank you.
We will now move into our second public
comment period. Again, this is open for
issues that were not previously on the
agenda this evening. Comments are
limited to three minutes per speaker.
Please begin with your name and block of
residence for the meeting record. Are
there any uh folks wishing to make
public comment in this period?
Tony Dastro, 700 block New Holland
Avenue. I guess I'm just ripping
tonight. Um
I have two subjects. Uh one of them is
just pretty direct. Uh, I've made this
clear that I think that Langster City
needs to start investigating rent
control and it's been stated by multiple
people in this room on and off the day
that state action is needed for us to do
that and that as far as I can tell is
just not a legal fact. Um, I would like
to see the council investigate this
further ask the solicitor as is your
right and ability to investigate this
and provide a report to the public
regarding the legality of rent control
in third class I'm sorry pulmer
municipalities like ours. Um, I think
the public deserves the full
understanding of the nuances of what we
can do and what we cannot do based off
uh the court case Philly lost back in
well wow I've lost a date. I think it
was 1955. Uh the second thing been
thinking a lot about the terms welcoming
versus sanctuary um and our city and
while I do know that this is a really
complicated issue right now because on
one hand we don't want to say anything
that makes us a bigger target. On the
other hand we are already a target.
the federal government, if they want to,
will crack down on us, Sanctuary City or
otherwise. So,
when I think about this issue, the more
I think about it, I I'm just kind of
left with uh I'm going to use a Bible
verse. Uh Matthew 5:14 and 15. I don't
have it memorized, but it's the one
where you are the light of the world.
You do not put a bowl upon a light and
keep it hidden. I feel like that's what
we're doing with calling ourselves a
welcoming city and not progressing
further to being a sanctuary city.
There's people all over this country who
are terrified. And while I understand
there's only so much we can do within
our powers as a government without
breaking federal law, the Underground
Railroad was not a government policy.
And we can we can help people. We really
can.
Thank you.
Any
additional speakers for the second
public comment period.
And I just wanted to add um the Spanish
interpreter that was here for
translation should have been translating
via
uh is this being recorded? I'm not sure
if it's if it's being recorded. She
should have been used because she was
asked to come for the Spanish-sp
speakaking people in Lancaster City
because they cannot make it to this this
off to a public comment or to even, you
know, see what's going on here. But
there are a lot of people that are
concerned in our city and they do they
are bilingual. So, I don't think it was
fair for you to turn her away, nor give
her a video recording or even have her
sit somewhere so that she can address
the public. This is a public setting.
And it's it's just wrong. It's just
wrong. Um I do want to also mention um
that um just making you aware of how
many city city employees, commuters,
firefighters, police officers,
taxpayers, disabled citizens in this
city that have been discriminated on by
Denine Sarra. Um, this mayor has caused
a lot of discrimination towards
citizens, hard-working taxpayers in this
city. And it's shameful that she's still
sitting there having to go to court for
all these accusations or offenses that
she has towards regular decent people,
turning a blind eye.
It's just not right. And I think that
she she should not be fit to be mayor. I
think she's the one that should stand
down because you've done enough.
Are there any additional speakers for
the second public comment period?
Hearing none, I will close it.
We will move to our next item on the
agenda, which is the report of the
mayor. Mayor Sarraji. Uh thank you very
much uh council president. Construction
season is upon us. Uh if you hadn't
noticed already, I wanted to briefly
share the planned street improvements
and paving lists for the 2025 uh season.
Uh the spring we will be doing Marshall
Avenue, uh base repairs, stadium road to
the city limits, alley 131, alley 10,
loop road from Mannheim Pike to um the
the dead end, Fremont Street, Hershey
Avenue to Charles Road, which I know has
been um long requested. Uh later in the
summer, West Strawberry Street, King uh
to South Water, East Mifflin Street,
South Plum to the Dead End, Claremont
Street, Stevens Avenue to South
Franklin, North Marshall Street between
New Holland A to Reynolds, North
Marshall Street, also East Walnut to
Lehi A. Uh in the fall, we will be
tackling Tennyson Drive, Buttercup Road
to Longfellow Drive, Browning Road,
Longfellow Drive. Um
yeah, Browning Road, Longfellow Drive
and North Plum Street, East Chestnut
Street intersection with selective mill
and overlay repairs. Um please note that
the timelines may change uh due to
weather conditions and other unexpected
delays. Uh residents should always be
mindful of posted signage during
construction. Um, and I just want to
note that from 2018 to 2024, the city of
Lancaster and our contractors have paved
25 miles of streets, about 20% of all
city streets. In 2021, the city started
paving streets ourselves rather than
relying on contractors. And since then,
we've been able to save just over a
million dollars by doing the work
inhouse. And um, we've been able to pave
more streets. Uh residents can use the
current construction map that's
available online um to monitor where and
when street improvements are happening
near them. The map can be found at city
of lancasterpa.gov/curren-
construction. Thank you councel. Thank
you mayor. Um and can I ask just a
clarifying question because I know that
people may have this question. It comes
up often. There's also in addition to
street uh improvements uh UGI work going
on across the city. Could you talk a
little bit about that and who is doing
that and how we know they're doing it?
Yes. So UGI is an independent
contractor. You'll often see trucks for
Miller Pipeline that are working in
neighborhoods. That information is also
available on the construction page. Um
they are responsible not only for trench
repair after they um dig uh holes in the
street to replace uh the gas lines and
meters and also along the sidewalks. But
then they have a a separate contractor
that comes back and repairs the entire
street as well as any cuts to sidewalk
that they may have patched along the
way. That work is completely separate
from and is regulated by the
Pennsylvania Utilities Commission. And I
know that it has been a source of a lot
of consternation for neighbors um in
terms of how they have done the trench
repair, where they have placed gas
meters, etc., etc. We continue to work
with UGI and as concerns are elevated to
us, we um work through our uh
construction operations division to be
in touch with UGI to do our very best to
advocate on behalf of the city of
Lancaster and its residents. Thank you,
mayor. Appreciate that. Our next item on
the agenda is report of president of
council. Um I have two uh brief items
this evening. um one uh relates to the
um CDBG plan and um a a presentation we
heard recently from our office of
healthy homes. I just want to put a
really fine point for anyone who may
have missed the last several meetings of
council. Uh our office of healthy homes
told us in May that they have over the
course of this lead grant as we call it
um completed $43 lead remediations in
homes in the city of Lancaster. The
average costs of those remediations were
about $17,500.
And I can't think of a better way to
invest the grant that we received from
the federal government than to make sure
that those 403 homes are free of lead um
so that families can live in them safely
um and that um they were not burdened by
additional rent increases because of
costly remediation otherwise. So I
wanted to make sure I highlighted that
this evening. Um also a reminder for
members of council that we will meet
next Tuesday. It's a a third Thursday of
the month I believe for us um to uh
start our work on the administrative
code that present that is a presentation
um that evening those work sessions will
be held here in city council chambers
and plate council chambers um at 6 pm
and those will be held on the third uh
Tuesdays of the month uh through the
summer. And finally just happy pride,
happy immigrant heritage month and world
refugee day. Happy early Junth.
So, that concludes my report.
Thank you. Uh, and the next item on the
agenda are council comments. Are there
any council comments this evening?
Council President, Councelor Craig,
um, I would just like to piggyback on
what Mr. Dastra said about um, for
anybody that has not seen the
reenactment of living the experience at
Bethlam Church, I went in
December.
And I used to play Lydia Hamilton Smith
in that reenactment
25 years ago when they first started it.
It has grown so much since then and it
is so good that I I would recommend if
you have not gone to see Living
Experience,
go see it. It's definitely Living the
Experience.
Thank you very much, Councelor Craig.
Any additional council comments? Council
President, if I may, Council Amed. Uh I
just want to thank the gentleman who
came out and spoke about the importance
of pedestrian and uh bikeless uh safety.
Um as I spent my afternoon uh visiting a
dear friend who's in the trauma unit in
LGH who was hit by a vehicle riding his
bike this past uh weekend.
um as he remains in our thoughts and
prayers, he also remains in our
commitment to safe streets and our
commitment to vision zero. And I want to
thank the other members of council for
the commitment to uh pedestrian and
cyclist safety. Uh it is serious um and
we continue to see um vehicles um just
simply have a disregard for people on
bikes as well as people who are
pedestrians. And um uh we need to
recommmit to um making sure that the
streets are safe for all road users no
matter how you use them. Um and uh my
dear friend is in my thoughts and um he
remains in my commitment. Thank you.
Thank you very much councelor.
Any additional council comments tonight
hearing none and having reached the end
of our agenda I will hear a motion to
adjurnn. Motion to second. We have a
motion and a second. All those in favor?
I I We're adjourned. Thank you.